the year is 1964 and it is beetle mania
time baby neil armstrong is training for
his moon mission fidel castro is uh
playing baseball and the world's
greatest hairstyles look a little
something like this
it's a look cotton this year between
hippies and hairspray the world was also
introduced to the little game show that
could called jeopardy a brand new game
with this mind-blowing twist it gives
you the answers and you have to give it
back the questions it's a it's an odd
very loose structure but hey it works
it's quick quirky cheap to produce for
daytime television little did they
suspect when jeopardy first launched
that this would be the thing to outlive
the wacky hairstyles the beatles breakup
neil's trips to space and even
uh fidel castro inspiring a love of
knowledge and trivia across multiple
generations to come and all of it was
guided by the show's warm and confident
host now here's the star of jeopardy art
loving good morning players
art fleming yeah it wasn't actually alex
trebek in those early days he actually
came later when the show was revived in
1984 with these spiffy new totally rad
80s graphics like look at that thing
it's like the ball is actually spinning
in three dimensions it's mind-blowing
and just like alex trebek wasn't
jeopardy's first host jeopardy wasn't
trebek's first hosting gig you see all
throughout his 30s he bounced around
between different game shows games that
nowadays are long forgotten like the
wizard of oz cute double dare uh don't
get too excited it's not the nickelodeon
version and the dice rolling game high
rollers now here's the man with the
action
trebek
[Music]
thank you very much look at that hair
also brief digression here but as i was
digging through all these archived old
game show clips i found this clip of him
hosting another show called battle stars
with celebrity guest betty white and the
only reason i bring it up here is
because this is 1982 and betty white is
still looking the way she does here in
diamonds and betty white are truly
forever anyway getting back on track
here when alex landed the hosting job
for 1984 as a revival of jeopardy it was
like a match made in heaven for roughly
the next 40 years audiences would
welcome alex into their homes every
single weeknight for their trivia fix he
was parodied welcome back to celebrity
jeopardy once again i'm going to
recommend that our viewers watch
something else he was animated aren't we
forgetting something marge you were down
fifty two hundred dollars judges
even swore a couple times where is alex
and in that time through it all he
became to viewers irreplaceable now i
don't know if you followed the news but
since alex trebek's tragic death last
year due to pancreatic cancer jeopardy
has been trying its darndest to find a
new host and they've been failing at it
pretty spectacularly to the point where
it's now a meme of its own putting the
whole future of the show into
pardon the pun
jeopardy basically the last year has
been like this revolving door of guest
hosts ranging from people that you'd
expect like all-time great players ken
jennings and buzzy cohen or famous news
hosts like katie kirk and anderson
cooper
and then some other more questionable
choices like football star aaron rodgers
who well seemingly a great guy just felt
like a really random choice as well as
dr oz who's been accused of peddling in
some very heavy non-science for a show
based on you know science and fact in
total 16 hosts cycled through with
varying degrees of success and it's been
popular for online articles to rank all
of them from best worst but with most
guests getting to host like five to ten
episodes seems unfair to judge when
considering there's 8 000 episodes of
the show and you're filming the shoes of
someone who was in that role for nearly
four decades so it's gonna take some
time to find your own rhythm but
regardless there were some high and low
performers it seemed like the former
winner ken jennings was the odds-on
favorite to take the job
at least until some off-color twitter
comments got him into hot water as it
does to so many throwing his chances
into question from there former star
trek and reading rainbow star levar
burton became the internet's clear
frontrunner for the gig and even
deadpool himself threw his hat into the
ring in defense of levar burton but
still the question on everyone's mind
was who was gonna take the job the
answer was revealed about two weeks ago
and it was
mike richards
never heard of him yeah
most people hadn't he's actually one of
the show's executive producers and
knowing that fact you can start to see
why people might be a little bit mad
about that decision here you have one of
the most prestigious and well-respected
game shows in all of history hosted by
alex trebek this man who is beloved and
respected by four decades of viewers the
guy in charge gives this incredibly
important job
to himself i mean don't get me wrong the
memes are great mike but this is not the
way to circulate your name around the
internet i guess he was all like you
want something done right you got to do
it yourself and i get that but at the
same time this is not a diy fix your own
toilet sort of moment there is no
youtube tutorial on how to replace alex
trebek until of course this episode so
maybe stick with the other potentially
more qualified more exciting candidates
and then the internet started to do what
the internet always does they started
digging into his past and of course they
found that he regularly made demeaning
jokes about women on his podcast about
their looks about their weight he would
make racist jokes jokes about the
homeless or people in poverty this
wasn't just an instance of one or two
off-color comments or a mis-phrased joke
it was a repeated pattern of behavior on
a show that he himself produced and so
only nine days after it was announced
that he was stepping up to be the
permanent ongoing host for jeopardy he
stepped right on back down jeopardy was
yet again without a host this in turn
threw the game show's taping schedule
into complete chaos and making the bad
situation even worse is that mayam
bialik the former actress of the big
bang theory and the show's other choice
of host to fill in for special event
episodes has also started to take heat
for past comments doubting the safety of
vaccines her criticism of birth control
her perceived victim blaming when it
comes to sexual assault in hollywood at
this point everyone is practically ready
to just throw up their hands scrap
jeopardy entirely and finally greenlight
the reboot of nickelodeon's gut
[Applause]
yes i do have it and don't get me wrong
well i would love to watch someone hand
out pieces of that glowing radical rock
and while i also appreciate the irony of
a show dubbed a sports competition when
you're trying to shoot basketballs
accurately while strapped to bungee
cords i don't think it's time to throw
in the towel on jeopardy just yet i
think i have a solution you ready for
this
it's me us
youtubers digital content creators i
know i know advocating for youtubers in
mainstream media you didn't see this one
coming from me it's not like i've ever
done this one before but really i truly
believe unironically that we have what
this show needs give us the chance to
host and okay i'm the first one to
lampshade that part of this comes from
my own love of the show i grew up
watching jeopardy i looked up to alex
trebek no matter how crazy my life got
he was this constant he was a rock he
was a role model that i watched
practically every night of my life at 7
30 pm eastern standard time to me he was
someone who encouraged the world to
always pursue knowledge no matter how
trivial and in no small way it was years
of watching jeopardy that inspired me to
make channels like this one that
celebrate education that celebrate being
smarter and just learning all you can
about the cool random stuff in the world
around you to me alex trebek was this
authentic figure not some big hollywood
host he felt real that was alex's x
factor and if that sounds familiar well
it should if you hang out on the
internet a lot you know that authentic
is the buzzword of us digital creators
since 2014 like omg us youtubers are so
authentic that's how they're shaking up
the entertainment system and well yeah
it is definitely super cliche to be
talking about it here in 2021 and also
it's not a guarantee that all youtubers
are authentic here in 2021 there is
still a lot of truth to that statement
online creators try to be real we need
to be real we try to connect with our
audience we try to be ourselves on
camera and be reliable figures that you
want to hang out with in your house on a
regular basis we don't answer the
network managers we're our own
barometers of what is and isn't okay to
put out there into the world we're
certainly odd most of us are more than a
little bit nerdy but let's be honest
what jeopardy viewer isn't and most
importantly we're people that our
audiences have formed a relationship
with they know us well enough to let us
into their house alex trebek became that
person for a lot of people just you know
he did it 30 years earlier than the rest
of us and he didn't have to do a
cinnamon challenge to get there the
other thing and this is a bit of tough
love for you network television but
we're younger shock of all shocks i know
this isn't coming as news to you but i
looked across the 16 guest hosts and the
average age was 53 for instance i love
levar burton and i think honestly with
time he would settle into that hosting
role nicely but it's worth mentioning
he's 64. he's 24 years older than when
alex got his start on the show and hey i
have been on youtube for 10 years at
this point so i'm all aboard the age is
just a number train this is not me
trying to say that you can't do amazing
jobs at that age but i will say that the
language of media is different now than
it was 40 years ago for the show to
continue for another 40 years it needs a
fresh look just like when alex got his
start in 1984 during the first big
jeopardy reboot i'm not saying that you
gotta go out and hire a member of hype
house to host jeopardy please do not do
that do not do that but i am saying that
the next host of jeopardy would do well
if they can believably speak across
generations all the way to gen z while
not alienating those long time viewers
of the show or should i say not
alienating them any more than the last
eight months have already done and a
younger host isn't just about preserving
the show's longevity it's about jeopardy
continuing to properly represent what
current relevant knowledge is don't get
me wrong i loved alex trebek but there
is a reason every time youtube or hip
hop or video games or memes were
mentioned in a clue it became really
awkward and that's because alex and the
other contestants are disconnected from
that world from this world a world that
let's face it is getting harder and
harder for the show to ignore if it
hopes to continue to grow to be sure
it'll always be valuable to know about
fine arts and geography and history and
science but at this point being literate
in internet social media yeah that's
just as important on top of being
connected to the trivia of today online
creators are connected with the
production itself want to produce a
format that's quick low budget and has
to be delivered in a really short amount
of time hmm
look around joe welcome to the club
friends except youtubers aren't just
acting in those cheap fast high burned
productions we're also writing and
producing and editing and working really
closely with the teams every single day
of that production and because our
brands are intrinsically tied to our
faces online we are meticulous about
ensuring that everything we touch is as
perfect as it can be i don't care if
your channel is react girl 23 and you
spend your whole day pretending to be
surprised by tick tick-tock kitchen
gadgets oh oh my gosh i can't believe it
does that you are still making sure that
every second of that video is exactly
the way you want it to be ah reaction
videos
miss the boat on that one matt the point
is this connectedness and attention to
detail matter when you're stepping into
a show with a pedigree like jeopardies
are there some bad eggs who've given
this community some less than stellar pr
in the past yeah absolutely but those
are few and far between in what is an
ocean of intelligence and talent that
exists in the digital space and that's
especially true the people that i'd
recommend for this job i know it's a big
internet out there so let me call out
some of my favorites there's derek from
veritasium diana aka physics girl
michael kevin or jake from the vsauce
channels marquez brownlee kyle hill
simone yetch hank and john green are
great destin from smarter every day i
don't know if channels like cgp gray or
kurzgestadt wouldn't be interested in
the job since they tend to stay off
camera but they would be brilliant in
their own right heck if you're looking
for a throwback even by heart would be
awesome here in 2021 these are the
people that audiences turn to for
information and that's not just me
blowing smoke in 2018 a pew research
study surveyed nearly 5 000 americans
and found that 51 used youtube videos to
learn new things more recent stats on
think with google say that the number
could be as high as 86 we are in a lot
of ways the public faces of knowledge
now the modern bill nyes or mr wizards
why not let us represent that on a shiny
floor in front of a big wall of tvs and
yeah this is totally where i volunteer
as tribute duh of course i would love to
host jeopardy it is literally in the
title of this video i would like to
nominate myself for the role i think i'd
be great and i know i should probably
lampshade this or state all the reasons
why everyone else is so much better how
i'm biased to my own opinion but you
know what i'm not i think i'm as much in
the running for this thing as all those
other awesome educators or all those
other 16 guest hosts who have been
cycled through the show at this point
i'm lucky enough to be in this amazing
cohort of educators i'm lucky enough to
be a jeopardy aficionado and i'm lucky
enough to be here at a time when the job
is open you get zero percent of the jobs
that you don't apply for so here i am
applying mike richards i have four
youtube channels that have threaded the
needle of education and entertainment
for the last 10 years i mean no one else
is going to be using minecraft to teach
audiences about the explosive properties
of moss or heck use the movie minions as
an excuse to talk about a lobster's
immortal telomeres i've always said that
these channels are educational channels
that are disguised as gaming film and
food channels with the goal of making
learning fun and wouldn't you know it
that's exactly what jeopardy is it's a
way to make nerding out fun for the
whole family and heck i've hosted thank
you for tuning in it is an honor to have
you today hopefully you're strapped in
for a long day full of fun and
excitement it's gonna be a good one this
is youtube originals presents game
theory's one million dollar challenge
for saint jude why am i sitting here in
this creepy recreation of a restaurant
it's a good question today we're
exploring the world of fear through
animatronic survival
restaurant horror gaming oh yeah it's a
real thing and here we go are you
excited i'm excited the game is on
welcome to a new breed of reality ladies
and gentlemen it is july 1st 2016. i'm
matt pat and this
is the runner are you in a relationship
i think this is important yes yes
happily married and candy are you in a
relationship okay i had my hot girl
summer
including hosting the most unruly group
of jeopardy contestants that you could
possibly have hoped for this dreamy
freddie where's that
krueger joel what
remember when i kindly asked you at the
beginning
he said machine gun kelly before you
were done you also said they won't be
penalized but to be fair joel i was like
most of the way i was like two two
thirds through the question i'm not
gonna be fair about that thanks for
disagreeing with literally everything i
said joel mchale
i was hoping that one day i would be
able to use some of those clips as a
part of an audition for jeopardy and you
talked through literally everything i
said so
really appreciate it do i think that me
or really any of the youtubers i
mentioned in this video can do what alex
trebek did no but the key detail that
this whole host search is for getting is
that the new host of jeopardy shouldn't
be looking to replicate what alex trebek
did there's a reason he's an icon that
can't be replaced because he did the
show his way trying to copy alex's act
will always read as false or just a
worse version of what he was doing this
isn't about filling someone else's shoes
it's about finding a new set of shoes to
stand behind the podium which is a
really awkward metaphor that i tried to
make work but i i think you get the
point anyway i am convinced that i or
any of those other names that i
mentioned would be great for the role
100 yes would we need some polish yeah
but let's be honest everyone does even
the most experienced broadcasters who've
stood behind that podium have struggled
to find their natural rhythm but for the
continued health and success of the show
the host answer may just be found in the
form of a question who is matpat so i've
laid all my cards on the table here i'm
not making bones about it i just want to
host jeopardy it'd be a dream come true
but all jokes aside i recognize that no
one from jeopardy is ever gonna see this
video some tells me they're not gonna be
watching film theory's analysis of the
future jeopardy host so this is where i
need you guys and your help see you
loyal theorists can help me get
jeopardy's attention in two ways and if
you have ever loved a video on this
channel or any of the other channels or
honestly any of the other youtubers that
i mentioned in this video do me a solid
first it took levar burton
000 signatures to get called on to host
an episode it'll probably take us at
least that much or probably even more
because we are really coming at this
thing as the underdogs so below this
video is a link go right now sign that
petition get your friends and family to
sign it basically i need as many
signatures as possible to just show that
there is a groundswell of support for a
digital creator to even have a shot of
hosting this show so if you could sign
that that would be great secondly if you
are on twitter tweet at the official
jeopardy account it's just at jeopardy
very easy use the hashtag who is matpat
i'm hoping with enough tweets and enough
hashtags they'll be interested they'll
be like who is matpat and they'll look
me up and i'll start a conversation
whether it's me or any of the other
youtubers i mentioned or a youtuber
who's awesome and i just don't know him
yet the fact of the matter is i love
this show and i love digital creators
and i care about both of those worlds a
lot would it be a dream of mine to guest
host for an episode or two yeah
absolutely it would be a dream come true
one of the greatest honors i could
possibly ever receive and that is
certainly a goal of this video but
ultimately what i really care about is
for the tradition to continue on strong
to move forward in a way that i believe
is gonna be best for the show so it can
go on and inspire more generations the
way that i was inspired growing up
watching it again thank you all for your
help the petition is right below this
video top line of description and a
tweet or two with a hashtag who is
matpat would be really helpful wish me
luck friends and remember it's all just
a theory a film theory and cuts
you